how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we waited so long for Avengers and gay
men it is finally here after an insanely
long year of waiting which felt like
forever the movie has finally hit the
theaters and it was amazing but of
course it was the culmination of the 22
MCU films wrapping up the story arc for
those first 11 years so now of course
everybody has been asking what is next
for Marvel and phase 4 well I'm gonna
break it down in this video also if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
can stay up to date on all things
related to Marvel and superhero so
before we dive into phase 4 we have to
technically end phase 3 a lot of people
think Avengers in game is the last movie
of phase 3 but it's not spider-man far
from home is the last movie of phase 3
and Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige
has already come out and confirmed this
and since spider-man far from home is
technically the last movie of phase 3
and we didn't get a post-credits scene
with Avengers in game perhaps we'll get
one for spider-man far from home to let
us know about phase 4 but even without a
post-credits scene leading us into phase
4 we still know quite a bit about it
for example Marvel already has
theatrical dates set on their calendars
in fact they have dates leading up to
2022 the dates read is followed May
first 2020 gel i thirty first 2020
November 6 2020 February 12 2021 may 7th
2012 1 November 5th 2021 February 18
2022 may 6 2012 2022 so starting next
year
Marvel is going to be doing three movies
a year until 2022 and these are all
without even mentioning the new shows
that are coming to Disney Plus that are
directly connected with the MCU but
let's start with all of the movies that
we know are coming to the MCU and Marvel
as I mentioned spider-man far from home
is coming July 2nd of this year 2019 it
will be the last movie of phase 3
getting them to face board there are a
bunch of movies that we know are going
to be coming one of them is the black
widows solo film a movie that a lot of
people have been waiting for since Iron
Man 2 according to reports Black Widow
production began in March of course it's
been confirmed that we are indeed going
to get a black panther 2 this is
surprising at all given how much success
the first Black Panther had and how much
people love to chela we also know that
we're going to be getting a shang-chi
movie Marvel's first movie with an Asian
lead shang-chi is an expert at martial
arts and according to reports Marvel has
already got Dave Callaham to be writing
the film we of course know that we are
going to be getting a Doctor Strange -
this has already been confirmed and they
have already brought in back scott
derrickson who directed the first Doctor
Strange film and it's been heavily
rumored and speculated that name war
will be the villain in Doctor Strange -
then we have the Eternals a movie that
Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios has been teasing for a very long
time casting rumors have already began
the fly saying that they've got an
Angelina Jolie to play the role of sir Z
although nothing is official at all but
it is fun to note that two of the
Eternals are Thanos as parents so
perhaps we have not seen the end of
Thanos in the MCU after all and then of
course we have the guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 which was set up perfectly
at the end of Avengers endgame Disney
has rehired James Gunn to direct the
film however he has to finish filming
Suicide Squad 2 first that comes out in
2021 so we can expect guardians vol 3 to
come out in 2022 then there has been
talk about a Miss Marvel film no this is
not Captain Marvel this is Camilla Khan
and inhuman who idolizes Captain Marvel
Kevin Feige said he wanted to introduce
Captain Marvel first before introducing
Miss Marvel well we have Captain Marvel
now so we can expect a Miss Marvel film
and speaking of Captain Marvel we can of
course expect a Captain Marvel - despite
mixed reactions from fans Captain Marvel
was a massive success in the box office
those are all the movies that we know
are eventually going to be coming into
the MCU into phase 4 Disney now
completely owns all of the Fox
characters such as the Fantastic Four
and the x-men Kevin Feige said that
we'll probably be waiting five years or
more until we see them enter the MCU but
you never know and we also have four
shows that are coming to Disney Plus
that have already been confirmed to
directly connect to the MCU we have a
Loki series coming a Falcon and Bucky
series coming a Wanda and vision series
coming and a reported Hawkeye series
coming again it has been confirmed that
these will take place inside of the MCU
and Kevin Feige has even confirmed that
these shows will be very important
factors of the MCU
so that's what you can expect for
Marvel's face for as you can see even
though Avengers in game is out and has
wrapped up the first eleven years of the
MCU Marvel is still very very busy and
they're going to be producing amazing
movie still so I hope this helped answer
some of your questions and I hope this
helps get you excited for the future of
the MCU but let me know what you think
about this and the comments down below
and of course again if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on everything related to
the MCU and all things superhero as
always thank you all so much for
watching and all it took
you said it cost you everything while
crying like a baby